-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show"!
You're here.
You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, the Tokyo Olympics
have officially come to an end.
Yeah, that's right.
Now if you want to witness
physical excellence,
you'll have to watch
a flight attendant duct-tape
a drunk guy to his seat.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, give that flight
attendant a medal, I think.
Come on.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That guy...
But it was a magical two weeks.
Night after night,
Americans gathered around the TV
to see the events where we
already saw who won on Twitter.
[ Laughter ]
It was just an amazing --
But this was exciting.
After an incredible last day,
Team USA topped the final
medal count with 113 medals!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
That's right -- 113 medals.
Meanwhile, all the country
wants to talk about
is how often celebrities bathe.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
The Olympics are over,
but if you're still craving
exciting, pulse-pounding sports,
ESPN's got you covered.
Check it out.
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
All day long.
[ Light laughter ]
Let's get to some news.
On Friday,
the White House announced
that half of all Americans
are now fully vaccinated.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
And this is cool.
To get those numbers up,
in the fall,
Pfizer just announced
a new pumpkin-spice vaccine.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
50% of the country
is fully vaccinated.
Is it just me, or does it
feel like a group project
where half the team
does all the work?
[ Laughter and applause ]
"What are you doing?"
Speaking of the vaccine,
United Airlines announced
that they're requiring
all of their employees
to get vaccinated.
But this is annoying.
They're now charging every
passenger a $9 common-sense fee.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Spirit Airlines
isn't requiring vaccines.
They were just like,
"We're just gonna fly
with the windows down."
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news.
I saw that KFC is opening
a hotel in London
that will feature
a "Press for Chicken" button
in every room.
[ Laughter ]
-Finally!
-If you're wondering who stays
at the KFC hotel,
just picture the exact opposite
of the Olympic Village.
That's who's --
[ Laughter ]
And did you see this?
In Oklahoma,
a truck carrying
more than 27,000 pounds
of women's
spray deodorant exploded.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
It was the first truck explosion
ever described as "Confident,
strong, and ready
to take on the day."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally, I saw that
London's Tower Bridge
was stuck open today,
causing traffic
to a grind to a halt.
You know the Queen was
at home, going, "I'm starving.
Where the F
is my Uber Eats guy?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show, everybody.
Give it up for The Roots!
-♪ My mind designed
a finer rhyme ♪
♪ And right on time,
I'mma step beyond ♪
♪ And not behind a line ♪
♪ Celebrate dawn for the rise ♪
[ Rapping indistinctly ]
♪ As a warning sign ♪
♪ Antonyms, words on
synonyms, homonyms ♪
♪ Cinnamon spelled like M&M's ♪
♪ Hey, yeah ♪
♪ To retain them again ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It is Monday, everybody!
We got a brand-new show tonight.
Billie Eilish is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have actually a giant week.
A giant week of shows this whole
week on "The Tonight Show."
Tomorrow night,
Barbra Streisand will be here.
-Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Billy Crystal will be here.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kit Harington,
Duran Duran will be here.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All-new "Tonight Shows"
the whole week.
We also have our author
of the Fallon Summer Reads.
"Our author."
-"Our author."
-Yeah.
It's everyone's.
America's author.
Jean Hanff Korelitz
will be on the show Wednesday
to talk about her --
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The Plot" is the book,
and I just finished it
this morning.
-Did you really?
Nuts.
-It's unbelievable.
Twists, turns,
turns upon twists.
And then twists one more time.
[ Laughter ]
It's like Chubby Checker.
-Does it twist again?
-Twist against
like we did last summer,
that song, the follow-up hit
to "The Twist."
[ Laughter ]
He's like, "I got it."
-What is it?
What's the new hit?
-How many years has it been
since "The Twist"?
-Like two?
[ Laughter ]
But you got another song in you.
I know you do.
-Yep. Well, "The Twist"
went like this, right?
♪ Come on, baby ♪
♪ Let's do the twist ♪
Check it out.
That's -- That's the old me.
-That's the old you.
-That's the old me.
I don't even remember that dude.
-Yeah, that guy's gone,
'cause this is the new
Chublin P. Checker.
[ Laughter ]
Lay it on them.
Lay that song on them.
-Now, people think they call
me chubby because --
-Right, because of Fats Domino.
-Yeah.
But no I'm --
No, my real name is Chublin.
-Chublin P. Checker.
-Chublin P. Checkers.
Checker.
Sorry. Not Checkers.
That's ridiculous.
So Chubby Checker...
-Yes.
-...who lost weight
doing "The Twist," by the way.
-Right.
-It was like a diet fad.
-It's an aerobic.
-He was hitting all the bases.
-Right.
-So I got you a song.
"You want a hit song?
You got it.
Do you want to lose weight?
Let's do 'The Twist.'"
Everybody does The Twist,
and now he just goes by,
you know, uh, Jared Checker.
[ Laughter ]
So he goes --
Yeah, so he's Jared Checker.
He's like,
"I lost all this weight."
And then you go,
"No. Keep 'Chubby.'" Right?
But how do you follow it up
with a second --
-What could possibly be --
-Let's not Twist
and gain it back.
-Right.
-So Chubby goes, "I got it."
-What's your song?
I can't wait to the hear it.
♪ Let's Twist again ♪
♪ Like we did last summer ♪
Yeah.
He does "Let's Twist Again."
That was his follow-up hit.
[ Laughter ]
And then --
Did he have any other hits?
-Yes, "Still Twisting."
-"Still Twisting," yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-He did not. Did he?
-Yeah, he did.
-He did.
-"Still Twisting."
-"Still Twisting"?
No, you're making that up.
-I don't even know how --
I know "Still Twisting's" a
song, but how does it go?
-It goes...
♪ Still Twisting ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Still Twisting"
would have been a giant hit.
-Yeah, huge.
-But didn't he --
He came back out
with The Fat Boys, didn't he?
Chubby Checker?
-Yes, in '87.
-Yeah.
-Wow.
And then was it --
-"The Twist."
-Yeah.
-"Twist in '87."
-Don't mess with the original
if the original's working.
-Twisting it up.
The cruller.
-Yeah. You know, I like
classical music, right?
-Oh, you love it.
-You know what I say?
-What do you say?
If it ain't baroque,
don't fix it?
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
But what a show we have
for you tonight, everybody.
She has the number-one album
in the country,
"Happier Than Ever."
Billie Eilish is here!
We're gonna talk to Billie!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then, she's performing
the title track
"Happier Than Ever"
later in the show.
Also, from the new film
"Stillwater,"
Abigail Breslin is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Abigail Breslin!
We love her.
Guys, before we go on,
I'd like to take a moment
to thank some of our sponsors
for tonight's show.
They don't always fit in the
commercial breaks, apparently.
So we want to make sure --
[ Light laughter ]
-Right.
-According to the cue cards.
Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
We want to make sure that we
mention all of the --
-Sure.
-So now it's time
for a thing called
"Tonight Show Sponsors."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Tonight Show Sponsors ♪
♪ Tonight Show Sponsors ♪
-Now. these are sponsors that --
-Didn't make it.
-To the commercial breaks.
-Right.
-So we're gonna help out.
-You're gonna say them now.
You're gonna
say their names now.
-That's correct. Yeah.
Here's the first one.
Tide -- We'll get blood
out of that shirt,
and we won't ask any questions.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Tombstone --
Ever wanted to destroy
the roof of your mouth
on something mediocre?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-Target -- Somehow you just
spent 140 bucks here.
We don't know how.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Fox News -- We're basically a
Facebook thread you can watch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oreo -- Still putting out
weird, new flavors
just to remind you
the regular ones are better.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Pizza Hut --
We're why that one bank in town
looks like a Pizza Hut.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter continues ]
Good & Plenty --
There are plenty,
but if you don't like licorice,
they're not good.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Tempur-Pedic --
Want to sleep in a baby pool
full of kinetic sand?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Tums --
Because you're 30.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, Red Roof Inn --
Think your mattress is stained?
You should have seen it
before we flipped it.
That's all we have
for "Tonight Show Sponsors."